foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome everyone to Dynamic
workloads at the right price we're going
to be talking today about Cloud run in
gke and how they can help you scale your
business
I'm kazem fields and I'm a developer
Advocate at Google Cloud where I focus
on Google kubernetes engine and open
source kubernetes and it's my birthday
so thank you for coming to my birthday
party that Google's drawing for me
[Applause]
we also have today my teammate Luke
schlangen who is also a developer
Advocate on gke and we're very excited
to have Andrew Moreland from chalk and
they're going to tell you a little bit
he's going to tell you a little bit
about Chalk's story of how they got
their business going and scaled with
Cloud run and gke
so to start off today we're going to
talk about scaling a little bit and what
we mean by scaling then we're going to
hear Chalk's story about how they've
been using Cloud run and gke then I'm
going to go over the essentials of what
you should know about Cloud run and gke
and kind of when to use them and we're
going to talk a little bit about the
Google for startups Cloud program
to start off let's go over what we mean
by scaling essentially
scaling is all about making sure that
your business has what it needs in order
to meet the demands that you're under so
Cloud run and gke are two tools that
Google Cloud provides that are meant for
handling scale they have really
interesting Auto scaling capabilities so
that as your demand shifts and changes
you're paying for the right amount of
resources to meet the demands of your
business
both Cloud run and gke have a variety of
features intended to make sure that your
workloads are being run in a highly
available fashion
they're also again a lot about scale so
making sure that as your uh demand goes
up you get more resources as it goes
down it also scales down so that you're
not paying for more than you need
it's about enabling your workloads so
whatever business you may be running
whatever programming languages whatever
kinds of applications you may need to
run Cloud run gke make use of container
standards to make sure that you can run
them we'll talk a little bit more about
that later and I've been talking about
responding to demand both of these have
a variety of features to help you do
that
but first let's hear Chalk's story from
Andrew to get give you a sense of how
this works in the real world
[Applause]
thank you cousin Mike I'm through okay
all right so my name is Andrew Moreland
and I'm one of the co-founders of chalk
at chalk we help companies and
industries like banking Healthcare and
e-commerce use machine learning to solve
problems like credit underwriting or
emergency room triage or product
recommendation
and the thread which ties all of these
use cases together is the problem of
getting the right data in the right
place at the right time our customers
need to integrate and transform data
from a variety of data sources so things
like postgres databases or bigquery or
Pub sub or Kafka you name it all sorts
of things they need to to tie together
to deliver data to their models
and today we're going to look at a quick
demo of how chalk uses Cloud run and gke
in order to execute workloads with
Dynamic resource requirements in order
to serve these customers
we're going to focus on two of the key
work key two of the key workflows in
machine learning the first is the
problem of online inference so the
problem of getting a single Vector of
features really fast to a model to make
a prediction right now
and the second problem we're going to
talk about is the problem of getting a
big table of data to go ahead and train
a model
so zooming out for a moment let's
imagine that we're a bank I don't know
how we would be a bank but let's pretend
we are
and suppose we want to do a credit
underwriting model fundamentally what we
want to do is take a huge amount of data
about individuals and their financial
behaviors and crunch that down distill
it into some sort of machine
which can predict the credit worthiness
of a particular person
so we want to understand can this person
pay us back do they want to will they
and the way we're going to do that is
we're going to compute what machine
learning practitioners call features a
feature is just a fancy word for a data
point that goes into a machine learning
model
so a thing like a person's name or their
favorite color their income how much
money they spend on burritos in the past
30 days could all be a feature but today
we're going to focus on features that
are derived from Financial transactions
which is a rich source of data for
underwriting
so zooming through this slide
let's take a look at some code
so on the screen right now is what we
call a feature schema so a feature
schema basically just has the names and
data types of the features that we want
to compute
um it's fairly straightforward but here
we're describing the features of a
transaction object so a transaction has
an amount has a bunch of other data and
it has a description so the thing that
shows up on your bank statement
but
the schema is not the interesting thing
about what we're doing today
here's an example of what we call a SQL
resolver a SQL resolver is one node and
a big graph that we're building up a
compute graph which we'll use to derive
the features that we're going to use for
our models
um that's SQL resolver which was there
for a moment and is now gone uh is not
very complicated it's basically just
mapping data from an underlying SQL
table into the feature schema we just
defined but once we've defined this kind
of foundation we can start to do things
that are more complicated
so what's on the screen right now is
what we call a python resolver a python
resolver is a more complicated construct
which is also part of that same compute
graph using the type signatures of its
argument list it can declare
dependencies on features that we've
already computed and it can tell us what
it's going to produce
ultimately what we're going to take in
here is the amount of a transaction and
the normalized description of a
transaction which is produced by what we
call an upstream resolver resolver which
has already gone through and cleaned up
that string that appears on your bank
statement
and then it's going to tell us whether
that transaction corresponds to a
telecom vendor so maybe like a cell
phone bill or something like that
and pausing for a moment what's why are
we doing this like intuitively why do we
care about this operation
so if you look in the problem of fraud
if you look at the transactions that are
in a bank account
uh intuitively if the transactions
correspond to normal everyday people
type things like groceries gas Mortgage
in the Bay Area probably rent
um a cell phone bill it's more likely
that that bank account corresponds to a
normal everyday person not someone who's
trying to steal money from us and on the
contrary if we don't see those sorts of
patterns in these accounts it's a
probably a big sign that this account
could be made by someone with a false
identity who's trying to construct a
situation where they can steal money
from us so it's a really powerful signal
to feed into our predictive models
and once we've defined this python
resolver
we can go ahead and query it
so on the right hand side you see the
output of running a query command
so what happened basically is we sent an
API request off to talk server ask for
two features the is telecom feature on
the normalized subscription feature and
chalk returned its output and in
particular we noticed that uh this
arbitrary transaction was just was uh
classified as not a telecom transaction
which is a little odd because we see a
Verizon bill payment in the description
so this raises kind of two points the
first is that data quality is really
important
if you have you know bad data if you're
telling lies to your models they're
going to tell lies back to you
so one of the things we want to focus on
is making sure that we have really high
quality future pipelines to deliver
correct data to our models so that we
can make high quality predictions
and that's one of the problems that
chalk is really engineered to solve and
the second thing here is that you know
things go wrong if feature pipelines are
rigid and hard to change it's really
hard to get that high quality of feature
output that we ultimately want to
deliver to our models so chalk is set up
to make it really fast and easy to
flexibly iterate on these feature
definitions
so on the left we've jumped to the
definition of one of those constants
that was in that python resolver
basically a list of keywords that we're
checking to see if they appear in the
transaction description
and we can do using Cloud run basically
is add a new constant to this list of
constants and the type chalk apply
weighed about 100 milliseconds and then
the new pipeline is live
and that leverages the ability of cloud
run to deploy tons and tons of pipelines
really quickly
and as soon as it's deployed it's ready
to be queried so we can see the change
we just made and see its impact
immediately so this gives us kind of
like a hot reload like modern web
development experience but for data
engineering pipelines which additionally
have been like fairly inflexible they
tend to have lots of global state
they're slow to change and hard hard to
understand what's going on in them
so we think this is a really amazing
developer experience and it's made
possible by Cloud run because basically
every time that a user makes a code
change and we can set like a watch
command up to do these automatically we
can ship off a new revision to Google
and it becomes immediately available for
querying but if it's not queried it
doesn't cost anything
it scales to entirely to zero and at the
same time if it is queried a lot it can
scale basically instantly up to 10 000
queries per second
so you have all these different
snapshots of your feature engineering
pipeline all these different kind of
forks and points in time which you can
choose to flexibly move between and
promote in order to have that modern web
development experience for data
engineering
so this is the first workflow I wanted
to talk about uh online inference but
the second workflow is also really
interesting
the second workflow is the problem of
getting training data so instead of
talking about a single feature Vector we
want to talk about many many feature
vectors so a big table of data which we
can use to go and train a model
so instead of running a query we're
going to run an offline query
make sure the video goes
all right
um so this offline query instead of
taking in a single transaction ID takes
in a big Vector of transaction IDs and
you can pass in a bunch of features you
want to know about these transactions so
not just from one data source we can
blend data from databases from computed
features from streaming sources from
batch sources like bigquery and
synthesize it into a unified table which
you can then pass off to whatever you
want to use to train your model like
scikit-learn or uh whatever you'd like
we're largely agnostic to that
um and what's going on under the hood
here is when you submit that query
Chalk's query planner sizes the query
understands how many resources you need
in order to execute it
and then spins up the right size
containers in Google cloud and Google
kubernetes engine automatically
so we basically automatically understand
how many CPUs and how much RAM you'll
need in order to compute this training
set
we make sure we have the right
containers if we don't we spin them up
we Shard the work distributed out and
get back the results all in a couple
seconds and gke makes it possible or gke
autopilot in particular makes it
possible for us to have this really
amazing interactive query experience
across data sets that have millions or
billions of rows while basically paying
for only a few seconds of compute
because we can step up and spin it back
down
and without chalk without GK autopilot
in order to get an experience like this
we'd often have to leave a big spark
cluster laying around all day paying for
tons of computers probably aren't doing
anything in order to make sure that our
data scientists have a really good
interactive experience
so fundamentally the combination of
cloud run and of gke in particular
autopilot gives us the ability to offer
a really incredible developer experience
kind of that modern web development hot
reload experience for our data
engineering Pipelines uh all at a really
affordable price point
so thank you for having me up here Luke
but um I wanted to talk about one last
thing which was the transition from
cloud run to gke so
you might be thinking kubernetes uh hard
takes a lot of time to switch to but
fundamentally uh Cloud run and gke have
approximately the same configuration API
under the hood so when we needed to make
that transition from cloud run to gke as
our business scaled and our workloads
grew larger than we can fit in a single
instance we were able to make that
transition and just that transition in
just about a single day so it really
isn't so bad if you do need to make the
switch
oh thank you
[Applause]
so in order to get our application out
into the world if that's what you're
looking for today if you're an a web
application developer like me and you
just want to get your application into
the world this is the fastest way to do
it it's a single command if you have
gcloud installed if you have a container
image already running
already in existence
this is the fastest way to get out there
and maybe you don't have a container
image already in existence you can use
source code to do this as well so you
can take your source code throw it to
Cloud run and if you have a Docker file
it can go through that if you don't have
a Docker file it can guess it can make a
best effort with webpacks and they can
put that together for you which is
really phenomenal so Cloud run scale
with Cloud run there is a point where
you'll move from cloud run to gke
potentially but I want to debunk a
really common myth here and that is that
it doesn't
uh handle scale well because Cloud run
can handle any amount of scale so let's
talk about Cloud around here five bullet
points that I want to run through before
I get to that headline of why you might
actually be moving from cloud run to gke
so the first any language any binary any
Library this is true of both Cloud run
and gke and that is because they're both
using that containerization fundamentals
right we're taking our code we're
putting it into a container and now we
can run it a whole lot of different
places which leads to Andrew's point
about how when and if you decide to move
from cloud run to gke you already have
this fantastically containerized
application and you can move from one to
the other you just put the image in your
yaml file for gke and say this is the
same image that we just talked about on
the previous slide
so Cloud run uses containers leverages
that power the reason I love it as a web
application developer is it's fully
managed after that line we ran it's
ready to go it's up and running and it
does Auto scaling for us so it's going
to automatically scale all the way up to
what we need and it's going to scale all
the way down to zero when we aren't
running it so if you want you can set
limits to that so say at most you only
want 10 instances and at a minimum you
will always want to have one ready and
up and running whenever you need it you
can do that within Cloud run so there is
a lot of potential within the bounds of
cloud run and that
includes you only paying for what you
use to the nearest 100 milliseconds so
there's a fantastic demo we'd recommend
you check out innovators Hive you can
see Cloud Run in real time scaling up
and down and you'll notice that while
pods are still ready at times you're
only paying for the ones that are
receiving requests so you're not paying
when the Pod is necessarily running in
the background we are scaling it for you
up and down so this is a phenomenal
place to get started and doesn't prevent
you from moving on to other things in
the end okay so I buried the lead here
and I promised that I would get to it
why might you move from cloud run to gke
like Andrew said so again to hammer home
the point it's not based on scale it's
not the number of requests you receive
because Cloud run can handle it whatever
you want however many requests you're
sending Tori to our application
Cloud run can handle it so when do we
move so Andrew pointed out the first
example that I'm going to use which is
instead of requests you want to Scale
based on something else so in his case
in machine learning not every request
needs the same amount of compute not
every request needs the same amount of
memory and he wants to scale precisely
based on the query so he has a query
planner he knows exactly how much memory
exactly how much CPU he needs in order
to run those queries that's what he's
scaling based on so he is looking at
something like gke the other example we
see something very often
where people don't have a single
application so so far we've talked about
Services where it's just a single
service a single back end and you're
sending requests to that single back end
and there Cloud run can scale up and
down to meet that demand but once your
application architecture starts to look
like this if your architecture or
diagram isn't a single box and you need
a whole lot of interactivity between
those different containers
you can orchestrate that with kubernetes
and that's another good sign that it's
time to move to kubernetes because
kubernetes can handle that well but of
course there's the old adage
with great power
comes great
oh come on with great power it comes
great
amounts of yaml yes we all said the same
thing at the same time fantastic thank
you so much and with that terrible dad
joke I'm going to hand it off to caslin
[Applause]
so now we're going to dive more into gke
and I love talking about kubernetes so
thank you for letting me talk about
kubernetes on my birthday
[Laughter]
so as Luke was saying gke has a lot of
potential for helping you to manage more
complex architectures it provides a way
for you to have finer grained controls
it has a lot more buttons and knobs for
you to use when you have those more
complex architectures or those workloads
that have very specific requirements
kubernetes and Cloud run and a lot of
cloud tools are really about distributed
computing the cloud gave us the ability
to have a whole lot of computers at our
fingertips at any given time
in Cloud run you're abstracting away a
lot of that complexity and just saying
hey what is the application that you
need to run we'll worry about the
back-end stuff for
kubernetes allows you more of that
control to say here are the machines
that are underlying my applications
here's the things that my applications
need from those underlying machines
and a great thing about kubernetes is it
allows you to tell it these things in a
declarative manner
so you tell kubernetes I have an
application it needs
gpus it needs ssds make sure that that's
happening for me and keep this many
copies of it up at any given time for
example you do all of this with yaml
as Luke was saying so that's declarative
application management with kubernetes
as we were saying another reason that
folks move to gke is you do have more
control over the types of Hardware that
you're using to run your applications
and as we've been talking about it
enables more complex architectures
kubernetes has the ability to when
you're running many different
microservices within kubernetes it has
special tools to make sure that they can
interact with each other and not things
that they're not supposed to be
interacting with so it's very good at
enabling complex architecture
but we're here today to talk about
scaling
so there are four dimensions of
scalability that you should know about
if you're considering using gke the top
two on this diagram are about workloads
the bottom two are about infrastructure
the two on the left are about creating
more or fewer of something
that's called horizontal Auto scaling
and it's usually what people think about
when you think about scaling workloads
or scaling kubernetes
the two on the right are what we call
vertical Auto scaling
so the vertical pod Auto scaler is going
to be helping you to set the requests
and limits
on your workloads so telling us how many
how much CPU how much memory that
workload actually needs node Auto
provisioning is about choosing the right
machine sizes that can give you those
resources that you need
so horizontal pod Auto scaler is going
to be creating more copies of your
workload or fewer and cluster Auto
scaler is going to be creating more
machines or fewer machines so all of
these work together
and earlier in Chalk's story we heard
about GK autopilot specifically so in GK
autopilot it's kind of a world between
pure kubernetes and serverless which we
were talking about with Cloud run
in the case of GK autopilot we set up
your cluster with enough Machinery
enough resources to meet your workloads
needs based on those resource requests
and limits and we essentially call it
nodeless kubernetes what's happening
behind the scenes in autopilot is we've
set up the cluster Auto scaler and the
node Auto provisioning for you
so we're configuring all of the
infrastructure underlying your workloads
for you
but you still have the ability to
configure a lot of things about how your
workload runs you could set up the
horizontal pod Auto scaler and the
vertical pod Auto scaler you can tell us
that you need gpus you can tell us that
you need ssds you have a variety of
tools available to you to make sure that
your workloads are running the way that
they need to using kubernetes to have
the machines underlying it that you need
and that's all I'm going to cover for
you today about gke itself
I hope that you learned something new
and something interesting today in our
talk these are the things that if you
took away anything I hope it'll be one
of these
first off as we heard in Chalk's story
that getting started with cloudrun and
gke isn't so bad they can seem very
scary at first but once you start
getting into them they work very well
together and Cloud run is often cited as
being particularly easy to get started
with so
both of them really are not so bad
Cloud run in particular is great for
simpler architectures and Standalone
services at any scale so it's not scale
that keeps you from running on cloud run
but perhaps a more complex architecture
or specific Hardware needs
gke provides greater configurability for
more complex architectures
and whichever tool you choose we hope
that you've seen throughout next that
Google cloud has the tools to support
your journey to scale
and we would like to bring Andrew back
up to the stage to talk about where
they're going with their business right
now
um yeah I'm very excited to announce the
release of some new functionality for
truck so we're releasing chalk branches
which is that functionality you saw back
in the demo earlier where you can make a
new deployment in about 100 milliseconds
so it gives you that really fluid
developer experience and we've also as
part of this release built the
capability of defining features and
resolvers in Jupiter notebooks so the
data scientists don't have to use an IDE
if they don't want to they can just try
out new features and new pipelines right
there and then deploy them
I think uh one thing that our customers
ask us often when they're considering
using generative AI is uh what should we
be worrying about how should we be
thinking about it and the thing that I
always tell them is that these models
are very powerful they're super fancy
but ultimately if you give them bad data
they're still going to produce bad
output I think a lot of people have
shown that in a bunch of quantitative
ways so the old Dodge garbage in garbage
out is still true
and a last note we've been part of the
Google for startups quad program for
quite a while now and obviously the
credits are great but uh one of the
other things which is maybe overlooked
about the program is the access to
technical experts so as we were using
Cloud run and using gke we got a lot of
help from some fantastic Folks at Google
so I wanted to say thank you for that
foreign